if you are a regular viewer of
simplytech you're familiar with elon's
love for big announcements and ambitious
deadlines for world-changing science
fiction projects now Elon recently
announced that Tesla is gearing toward
the mass manufacturing of a futuristic
looking fully self-driven Robo Taxi by
the year 2023. so in this video Let's
examine that claim a little bit more
closely and see the future of
self-driven transportation from elon's
point of view the Genesis of Robo taxis
the concept of Robo taxis is not new at
all Elon first talked about the
metessa's autonomy Day event in April of
2019. in that event he said I feel very
confident predicting autonomous Robo
taxis for Tesla next year of course that
did not happen no one could have
predicted then that the year 2020 would
throw a spanner in the works for
everyone around the globe and Tesla was
no exception after elon's announcement
it was understood that Tesla was
planning to include the robo taxi as a
an additional feature in its existing
models the idea was to get to a stage
where Tesla owners would rent out their
fully self-driving cars as autonomous
Robo taxis in an Uber style model yeah
the idea sounds Bonkers when you think
about it but Tesla has been well on its
way toward realizing that goal with its
fully self-driving or FSD chip and AI
software suite I made a video about
Tesla's new neural net Network recently
you can check that out for more on that
but coming back to the topic though the
announcement of 2019 was the Genesis of
Tesla's Robo taxis phenomenon in his
announcement in Texas earlier this month
Elon paints a completely different
picture of what he means by Tesla Robo
taxis here Elon says that Tesla will be
manufacturing Robo taxis as a separate
vehicle on a massive scale these will be
dedicated self-driving cars presumably
owned and operated by Tesla themselves
whose only purpose would be to Ferry
people from point A to B creating a
parallel robot driven network of public
transport next to the the human driven
one now this is a whole nother ball game
than what we were given to understand
from his previous announcement at
autonomy day in 2019. obviously Elon
hasn't confirmed whether that initial
idea of existing Vehicles being able to
transform themselves into Robo taxis
still has the green light from his end
but as we will discuss later in this
video we believe that would be the first
step in Tesla's journey of getting to a
future where its Robo taxis would be
commonplace at least in North America to
begin with the biggest ticking point in
realizing this future is not in the
physical Hardware as we know but the
software side of things so the question
begs itself at what stage of development
is Tesla's self-driving technology for
Elon to now come out and confidently
make such an announcement the software
solution Tesla's experiment with all
this began with its autopilot technology
since then it has poured in significant
resources to develop in-house capability
toward creating a self-driving AI which
is now known as Tesla full self-driving
or FSD Tesla's FSD has improved by
orders of magnitude in the last couple
of years so much so that the company
released its public beta in 2021 to be
tested on the roads of San Francisco by
Tesla owners the program has exploded
since then and currently has over 60 000
drivers testing this FSD beta in all
sorts of conditions and Elon just
announced that by the end of this year
FSD will be rolled out to all Tesla
customers in North America not only does
this decision display Supreme confidence
in the progress that Tesla has made in
its self-driving software it also tells
us that Tesla has been able to
successfully develop the infrastructure
in the back end to absorb and learn from
the enormous stream of data that is
already being fed into its Network by
thousands of cars on the road every day
FSD beta testing involves automatic data
collection through complex data curation
methods and also manual data collection
beta testers can press a button on their
touchscreens to manually flag a segment
of their drive or review by Tesla this
has a allowed Tesla to already train up
its ai's neural network like no other in
fact many experts believe that Tesla is
just a few years if not months away from
realizing the full capabilities of this
software with every update of the
software we are seeing performances that
are off the charts cars are steering
themselves around 90 degree turns with
ease they are making unprotected
Crossings through intersections all on
their own and the amount of zero
intervention trips is steadily climbing
as the Tesla AI builds a more accurate
picture of the world around it so when
Elon claims that we could see production
Robo taxis rolling out of gigafactories
in some form or another by 2023 we can
be relatively certain of this timeline
but no doubt that there are a lot of
challenges yet to overcome as this
process of getting fully fledged Robo
taxis will be more of a gradual change
rather than an overnight breakthrough so
let us try to pick up the trail of
breadcrumbs left by Elon in his various
announcements and predict the steps that
Tesla will likely take to get us to that
future Tesla Robo taxi version 1 1.0 if
you think about it with the FSD beta
testing we are currently living through
Tesla's Robo taxi version 0.5 in just
over a year of testing no collisions
have been reported and the system works
perfectly 95 times out of 100 with a few
odd mistakes here and there if this can
be achieved in just a year of testing
with a handful of beta testers imagine
what can be achieved when Tesla launches
the FSD on all its Vehicles across North
America later this year Tesla will
immediately start receiving an
infinitely wider range of data that will
allow its Engineers to solve the final
piece of the self-driving puzzles that
much faster with all his announcements
Elon is definitely hinting towards that
future where self-driven Robo taxis will
become commonplace and we can see this
mindset reflected in Tesla's physical
designs as well the interior design and
the features proposed in the new model X
or the Cyber truck are definitely
representative of this I mean Tesla is
certainly not putting in an overpowered
AMD ryzen processor or an rdna 2 GPU in
the infotainment system of the latest
models for you to just watch the
navigation screen and play music on them
right they definitely Envision you being
totally hands off playing video games on
your way to work very soon according to
me the most compelling evidence that
Tesla has already taken the first step
toward that future is the bizarre Model
S plaid it is probably the most exciting
car to come out in a while the car's
interior is designed with a total lack
of any buttons or levers and I believe
the futuristic looking half steering
wheel is Tesla's way of telling us to
get used to a future where the steering
console becomes less and less relevant
as cars become more and more
self-driving Elon describes the model S
plaid as a car having an integrated
robotic chauffeur who will intuitively
learn your driving habits over time and
as it learns it will gradually reduce
the number of driver inputs down to zero
so imagine a day when all you need to do
is just sit back in your car buckle up
and it will automatically take you to
your destination and back without a
press of a button if you you are always
on the go your car can automatically
sync up with your digital calendar and
take you to your appointments without
you having to turn on the navigation
when Tesla can achieve this car owners
will start thinking about their personal
cars more like a cab rather than a car
that has some self-driving features this
would transform a Tesla car into a
personal cab that is at your beck and
call and you can rely on it to move you
around from point A to B without having
to provide any input at all that in my
mind would be Tesla's first Robo taxi
version 1.0 but with this cyber Rodeo
announcement earlier this month Elon has
also given us a glimpse into what's
going to be the Tesla Robo taxi version
2.0 dedicated self-driving Vehicles
operating within a Tesla Network
zigzagging the city streets of North
America providing an alternate means of
public transport to people and probably
also at a fraction of the cost this to
me would be the second step in the
evolution of Tesla's Robo taxis the
future of Tesla's Robo taxis I am sure
that in elon's mind the future of
sustainable trans transportation is when
people slowly move away from the concept
of personal ownership of cars and start
seeing them more as a service that they
use on a daily basis to get to places in
this future Robo taxis will become
ubiquitous and Elon wants Tesla to be
the harbinger of this change as
self-driving technology is developed
further and slowly permeates our society
Humanity will reach an inflection point
where an average person will start to
lose interest in owning a car as private
property to be honest I would prefer
that future when I can do away with
owning a car along with those expensive
monthly payments and recurring expenses
on a rapidly depreciating asset elon's
recent announcement that Tesla will
start producing dedicated Robo taxis
from 2023 gives us a unique glimpse into
where he expects Tesla to be in that new
Future these Tesla Robo taxis version
2.0 as I call it can very well be
vehicles that were never designed to be
driven by humans maybe even designed
specifically to travel at high speed
through underground tunnels or
completely optimize for for a high
volume production and public use no
matter what the Tesla Robo taxi of the
future looks like this is for sure Elon
and Tesla are already thinking about
dominating this space by planning to
operate a large network of these fully
autonomous Robo taxis in the very near
future and what's more it makes perfect
Financial sense as well imagine the
revenue that can be generated by a fleet
of Robo taxis where each vehicle has the
potential of generating a steady stream
of revenue for Tesla over its entire
lifespan instead of the one-time Revenue
that Tesla generates now when it sells
its cars to customers imagine a future
where Tesla is producing millions of
such Vehicles every year the amount of
money that can be generated by a network
such as that is staggering and Beyond
Comprehension at the moment and come to
think about it if the idea plays out
according to elon's Vision it is a real
possibility that in the foreseeable
future Tesla might stop selling cars
altogether as this segment of their
business turns out to be endlessly
profitable I would venture a guess that
by the end of the next decade the world
would definitely be talking about
Tesla's new Robo taxi Network in the
same way we talk about its latest cyber
truck of course before all that becomes
a reality Tesla has to overcome a lot of
regulatory and legal obstacles no doubt
and perhaps even find a solution to its
battery problem once and for all but I
remain confident about elon's timeline
of seeing some version of a Tesla Robo
tax even if it is a concept by the end
of 2023 do you agree with me when do you
expect the Tesla Robo taxi to take to
the streets let me know in the comment
section below and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel if you enjoyed
this video see you in the next one